le gard l'hérault et la lozère sous un
déluge d'eau donc depuis hier soir les
équipes de secours sont totalement
débordés
quatre personnes sont portées disparues
leurs voitures auraient été emportées
par des rivières en crue
nous attendons le reportage de nos
correspondants yannick à rossi et
jean-françois giorgetti je vous propose
tout de suite dans un premier temps de
faire le point sur les autres régions du
sud est qui n'ont pas été épargnés non
plus à des degrés divers donc le tour de
france des inondations agnès molinier
ici aussi à albi dans le tarn la rivière
a quitté son lit de très nombreuses
routes sont rendus impraticables des
ponts sont fermés et plusieurs dizaines
de maisons ont été évacuées dans
plusieurs départements du languedoc
roussillon les cours d'eau ont dépassé
les côtes dallaire les précipitations
ont été particulièrement violente dans
l'hérault dans le massif dès cévennes
sur le mont aigoual par exemple il est
tombé 420 litres d'eau par mètre carré
et ce pendant trois jours les routes
secondaires sont coupées les pompiers
n'ont cessé d'intervenir pour évacuer
les familles surtout des personnes âgées
les rois bien sûr déborder ce matin son
niveau a quand même baissé de 30 cm mais
localement on craint une forte remontée
de vous dans les heures qui viennent
il n'y a pour l'instant que des dégâts
matériels mais dans l'aveyron aux
alentours de millau les secours
n'avaient toujours pas retrouvé ce matin
le conducteur d'une voiture emportée par
le courant